[Music]
we've all heard about how on-screen
kissing can be
incredibly awkward but sometimes it's
just the opposite it can even lead to a
real-life romance
keep watching to see which famous
co-stars really felt the heat when they
locked lips while the cameras were
rolling
mila kunis grew up on the small screen
as she started playing
jackie on that 70s show when she was
just a teenager
for eight seasons audiences enjoyed
watching her overbearing
mouthy character gripe at her dim-witted
boyfriend michael kelso
played by ashton kutcher but what a lot
of fans didn't realize at the time was
that kunis's on-screen kisses with
kutcher were also her first kisses in
real life
in 2001 she talked with people magazine
about the moment that she realized she'd
have to smooch kutcher
as she put it i was like oh he's so cute
it's the calvin klein model then i was
like
i have to kiss him i was so nervous and
uncomfortable i had the biggest crush on
him
kutcher had no idea that he was kunis's
first kiss but their onscreen chemistry
made a decades-long lasting impression
in 2011 she ended her relationship with
home alone star macaulay culkin
and that same year kutcher separated
from his wife demi moore
soon thereafter kunis and kutcher
started hanging out and hooking up much
like his character in no strings
attached and her character in friends
with benefits
and if we would have just paid attention
to how those movies turned out we would
know that we can't go into a
relationship this way
yeah and yet we did exactly as both
those movies
they ultimately discovered that they had
a deep connection that proved to be
undeniable
they got married in 2015 and now they
have two kids together
from 2008 to 2014 hbo viewers were
enamored with sookie stackhouse as
played by anna paquin on the
supernatural series true blood
the show was a big hit thus proving the
eternal appeal of vampires werewolves
witches and other mythical creatures
paquin captured the hearts of millions
with her performance as sookie including
that of her co-star steven
moyer from the moment the two actors met
for their chemistry read moyer was
absolutely taken with paquin on the show
his character the sensitive vampire bill
compton
agonized over his love for sookie which
was in direct contrast to his fate in
the underworld
but in real life moyer and paquin's
relationship was
much less agonizing they got married in
2010 and welcomed
twins poppy and charlie in 2012.
they currently co-produced the amazon
series flack in which paquin plays a
tortured publicist
what's the secret i have twins in a
full-time job
that would do it how hot does your wife
look oh my goodness isn't that that's a
good minute
the strikingly handsome irish german
actor michael fassbender has a history
of hooking up with his colleagues
after playing a struggling addict in the
2011 indie flick
shame he briefly dated his co-star
nicole buhari
he also dated zoe kravitz after they
starred together in x-men first class
but when he starred opposite alicia
vikander in the 2016 romantic drama the
light between oceans he was so smitten
that his serial dating came to a halt
a classically trained ballet dancer
vikander gained
plenty of notice for playing a robot in
the offbeat 2015 sci-fi flick ex
machina the following year she won an
oscar for the danish girl
that same year fassbender was nominated
for the title role in the biopic steve
jobs
this powerful acting duo tend to keep
their romance on the down low
though a few shots of their secret 2017
wedding in ibiza did pop up on the
internet
their careers meanwhile are anything but
loki as vikander is set to reprise her
role as the new lara croft in tomb
raider 2
and rumors are swirling that fassbender
will star in a reboot
of the wild bunch after starring in the
likes of avatar and colombiana
zoe saldana was eager for more action
films to come her way
the 2012 mystery romantic drama the
words was the total opposite of this
desire but she nevertheless soon
connected with the role with the help of
her co-star bradley cooper
as a writer who steals someone else's
work to become famous cooper was
charismatic but
afflicted by his secret playing his wife
saldana was supportive but no nonsense
and their chemistry jumped off the
screen
okay i gotta fix this fine
you're missing out cooper and saldana
were romantically linked for a year and
their ultimate split resulted in some
professional awkwardness
as the actors had to spend some more
time together on the red carpet as they
promoted the words
zaldana eventually married italian
artist marco porrego in 2013
and the couple have three sons together
as for cooper after several short-lived
romances he got serious with his model
girlfriend irina shake and they had a
daughter together in 2017
though they separated in 2019
ryan gosling and rachel mcadams seemed
like they were destined to meet each
other they were both born in london
ontario canada though they took
different paths to success
gosling was a child actor on the mickey
mouse club while mick adams studied
theater at york university and made her
hollywood debut in the 2002 comedy the
hot chick
they were paired up soon after in the
2004 romantic classic the notebook
based on the nicholas sparks novel of
the same name the movie was an instant
hit
thanks in particular to the explosive
chemistry between its leads
you want to dance with me
sure
now playing conflicted lovers noah and
ally
gosling and mcadams initially had a hard
time finding their romantic rhythm
in 2014 director nick cassavetes told
vh1 that gosling even wanted to work
with a different actress
but they eventually worked it out and
their fiery on-screen love soon crossed
into real life as they started dating
but their demanding schedules got the
best of them as they parted ways in
2007.
since 2011 gosling has been with his
longtime girlfriend eva mendes with whom
he has two daughters
and as for mick adams in 2016 she
started dating her current partner
screenwriter jamie linden with whom she
has one son
jennifer goodwin's career has seen her
often play the girl who has a hard time
getting a guy
in the likes of mona lisa smile and he's
just not that into you
she puts all her cards on the table for
men who aren't exactly the most
emotionally available in 2011 something
borrowed she falls for her best friend's
fiance
and on the hbo show big love she shared
a husband with two other women
but on the abc fantasy series once upon
a time she
played snow white and appropriately
enough she finally found her prince
charming
josh dallas was the actor who played
charming on that show and he also swept
goodwin off her feet in real life
as she recalled during an appearance on
live with kelly and michael
i knew that in fact i was going to marry
my husband josh at disneyland
because i took him for his first time
ever and we had just started dating
we were on big thunder mountain and he
threw his arms in the air and he goes
this is the best day of my life and i
was like we're totally getting married
the couple went public at the 2012 white
house correspondents dinner and then got
married in 2014.
they welcomed their first son that same
year and a second one in 2016.
when dallas is away for work he likes to
send his wife flowers and face time with
her as much as possible
you guys are like a real hollywood story
was it love at first sight love on the
set yeah basically
there were so many twists and turns on
the scandalous abc show revenge
which starred emily van camp as emily
thorne a young woman who makes her way
into the lives of the wealthy grayson
family to get revenge for her father's
death
she uses the romantic interests of
grayson's son
daniel played by josh bowman to uncover
their dirty secrets
it was quite a different part for van
camp at least compared to her work as
sharon carter in the marvel cinematic
universe
though her revenge character's
intentions were fake there was nothing
fake about the romance that was
blossoming off screen between van camp
and bowman they attempted to keep their
budding relationship private but the
paparazzi caught them engaging in
heavy pda all over los angeles in 2017
vancamp announced their engagement in a
cute instagram post
and then they got married in the bahamas
the following year
when jennifer lopez met ben affleck on
the set of 2003's gili she was already a
married woman
the movie was notoriously panned by
critics with the lead's
lack of on-screen chemistry at the
center of much of the criticism
but they didn't let that negativity stop
them from working together again
as they also played husband and wife in
2004's jersey girl
and then they went public as a real life
couple once lopez
separated from her choreographer husband
chris judd
in 2002 affleck appeared in lopez's
music video for jenny from the block
in which they acted out much of the
tabloid fodder and lack of privacy they
were experiencing in real life
that same year lopez showed off the
blingy pink diamond engagement ring
affleck gave her which costs
a whopping 2.5 million dollars but all
that glitters
isn't gold and a year later the couple
called off their wedding
the flashing bulbs and constant
attention were just too much for them to
handle
lopez went on to marry singer mark
anthony in 2004 though they divorced in
2011
and she's now been engaged to alex
rodriguez since 2019.
as for affleck he was married to
jennifer garner from 2005 to 2018.
nicole kidman and tom cruise first met
when she auditioned for the 1990 sports
drama days of thunder
as she recalled in 2016 on the just
kegel interview
i walked into the audition and tom was
the one that stood up
and shook my hand and i just remember
electricity going through me
kidman played a doctor who checked on
the vitals of cruz's race car driver
and whatever she felt in her audition
translated on screen as their scenes
were purely electric
soon after the movie wrapped the two of
them got married cruz was a bonafide
superstar at the time while kidman was
still on her way to reaching her highest
levels of fame
when the couple appeared on screen
together again in stanley kubrick's 1999
psychological drama eyes wide shut
audiences speculated about whether their
character's marriage issues mirrored
kidman and cruises in real life there
may have been something to the
speculation as they split up in 2001
after 11 years of marriage cruz would go
on to be married to katie holmes from
2006 to 2012 while kidman married
country crooner keith urban in 2006.
in 1989 johnny depp was a teen
heartthrob hot off his starring role
on the fox police procedural 21 jump
street
while winona ryder fresh off of heathers
was already the poster girl for the
burgeoning alternative scene of the era
the stars aligned when they met at the
premiere of the 1989 movie great balls
of fire
they locked eyes and as depp recalled to
rolling stone
it was a classic glance like the zoom
lenses in west side story and everything
else gets foggy
depp made a big impression on ryder as
he was her first kiss
first boyfriend first fiance and first
person she slept with
they got engaged after only five months
of dating and depp famously got a tattoo
that said winona forever
they starred together in the quirky 1990
tim burton film edward scissorhands as
love interests who are ultimately pulled
apart
life imitated art for the couple as they
parted ways
after four years of dating after the
split depp changed his tattoo to wino
forever
in 2020 ryder testified on depp's behalf
during his abuse
trial against his ex-wife amber hurd on
the witness stand she stated
i truly and honestly only know him as a
really good man
an incredibly loving extremely caring
guy who was so very protective of me
and the people that he loves and i felt
so very
very safe with him check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you